How wasn't staring at you.
I see where I was looking at you making
sure it wasn't a dream. I was like, okay,
I'm Keyona Morrison.
I am 33 years old and
I'm a marketing manager.
My name is Cameron Morrison. I'm 33
years old and I'm a building engineer.
Were married for five years.
We have one and one on the way.
I'm nine months now,
so I should be having this baby any day.
Wow.
So I had just moved to La.
I had a friend in town who
was an aspiring actress.
She invited me to one of
her plays and we met there.
He kept asking me questions and looking
at me from across the room and I'm like,
Weirdo. She'll probably tell you that I'll
staring at her. But you know, I was uh,
actually trying to assure that there
was a connection. I thought there,
there might've been a connection to a,
one of the conversations she was,
she was pretty personable, easy going,
I saw you get up after party. Right.
And he kept staring at me. I wasn't
staring at you. I see where, all right.
So one of the first day I was
wanting to show around La really, uh,
we went to Venice beach,
we had to kind of navigate around the
crowd and I was really impressed how well
she walked with me. And I think
that's one of the things that, that,
that told me I needed to
look for a second date.
He probably didn't tell you this part,
but when he first picked
me up from my apartment,
I told him the wrong address so
that he wouldn't know where I lived.
I know that he took me to Venice beach.
I just remember him like putting his
arm around me and us walking through the
crowd and I just felt comfortable.
So we went to Venice beach after
I picked her up down the street.
Murphy,
I remember that we were walking
together like we knew each other.
We were comfortable. I think I came
home from work one day, you know,
I'm just in the routine. Come up the
stairs, drop my stuff off at the door.
She was up, had the lights on and
uh, no, she wants to pray with me.
So we bought our heads and at the end
of the prayer she asked God to just
prepare us,
prepare our steps,
prepare me to be the father
that she was now pregnant with.
It was crazy. I found out I was on a
business trip, so I had to hold it.
I think I was gone for three
days. And you know, I tell my mom,
my sister on the phone
and then when I got home,
I had the pregnancy test.
I recorded him and his reaction,
I think I just gave it to him. He was
shocked and he just kept saying, wow,
wow,
you came home,
came up the stairs and I think
I just gave you the, we pray,
we prayed. And then at the end of the
prayer you ask God to, uh, oh my gosh.
Apparently I forget that prepared
me to be the father, you know, hey,
you're like,
wait a second.
It was pretty much everything I thought
he would be because I knew those
qualities existed in him.
He's caring. So with Nala,
it's just on another level. He loves
the hell out of that girl. And,
and she loves him too.
She's strong mother.
I don't know how she
already knows what to do,
but it seems like she's been doing this
for a while. Yeah. That's impressive.
I don't have doubts or reservations
about the next one coming in the world.
You're just a good dad. Like she's
got you wrapped around her finger,
like she's going to be the spoiled little
girl because of you. That's all right.
I'm really just coming to terms with the
party being over and really mentoring.
Um,
a lot of time shooting myself in the foot
with my drinking. One time I
came home and you know, she,
uh, she said something
that really triggered me
and
you know, I know I yelled at her.
I don't know exactly what I say it,
but I know I was yelling at the
top of my lungs. She was fearful.
She was scared and uh,
wasn't pretty
definitely dealing with
Cameron's sobriety.
He's one way when he's sober
and then when he drinks,
he's a completely different person.
He wasn't abusive at all or anything,
but it's just he changed.
They are things that are forgiven,
but they can't really be
forgotten without the alcohol,
without the distractions.
He's everything.
I like,
I know what his intentions are and
they would never to hurt me on purpose.
So,
okay.
Dealing with, you know, my drinking,
dealing with my smoking. Yeah.
It just really making some,
some difficult changes with my life.
I forgave you,
but it's,
there are triggers that come up for
me and so it brings it all up again.
I'm way better at pushing them
out. I'm glad that, you know,
I have here forgiveness, you know, I
struggle with forgiving myself. You know,
I'm the one that hurts you the worst.
I know who you are
outside of that guy who over drink.
Well we've all done that and I feel
like since I did it in college and I've
grown up,
like why can't you do the same thing?
But it just took you a
little longer to realize,
oh absolutely.
I see is getting old and retiring or
some kind of farm somewhere somewhere on
the country.
I look at old couples and I think of
us like I think that Cameron and I are
going to be one of those cute old couples
that are still enjoying life together.
I'm excited to see him evolve
as a father as well. I mean,
I don't know how he can get any better,
but I just,
I'm excited to see it
as we raise our kids.
I mentioned us on out of on
a farm somewhere, you know,
I guess. Yeah, but you know,
honestly wherever we are, it doesn't
matter as long as we were together. Yeah,
we're still walking
together. Yeah. Father God,
we thank you for bringing us to this day.
We thank you for opening kiln and I up
to I see ourselves and to see the path
that you've brought us down so far.
All the obstacles and hurdles
that you've gotten us over.
Thank you for the health of our children.
We thank you for this pregnancy and pray
for the health of the child that's on
its way and we ask that you
just continue to be present,
get to continue to lead our way.
Amen.
Okay.
I say it's the moist were
back within a new, uh,
Morrison this design.
Scott Nolan Moon.
Ooh,
science here.
Huh?